okay today I'm going to talk to you
about percentage yield calculations so
we're going to look at what percentage
yield actually means and then we're
going to complete the calculation to
show how that works so yield just means
the amount of product produced now let's
just have let's just imagine is let's
imagine in a lab we were doing a series
of reactions between some reactants to
make product now let's imagine this if I
have 40 grams of this and I had 10 grams
of this my theoretical yield would
obviously be 50 grams I'd expect to be
making 50 grams of this however in
reality this is never the case now the
reason for that is well there's three
different reasons first of all we could
have loss of material so it depends on
what we needed to do to mix our
reactants together if we transferring
liquids from one container to another
some of those liquids could be left on
the inside of the container also if we
were evaporating some bits could kind of
just kind of spill out when the
evaporation was happening so we could
lose some material which means this
number would go down a bit we could also
have on wanted reactions now what that
means is there could be some kind of
impurities that our reactants react with
meaning we don't get our desired
products or that much of our desired
product and also we could have
incomplete reactions meaning that not
all of our reactants ended up reacting
so in reality we never actually get our
expected our theoretical yield we always
get less so let's say in this particular
example we got 45 grams opposed to 50
grams now to find our percentage yield
what we need to do is find a actual
yield with what we actually got a mix in
our experiment divide it by a theorist
yield so what should we theoretically
got and then we just multiply that
answer by a hundred so 45 divided by 50
multiplied by a hundred this particular
experiment will have a 90% yield now
what that means is 90% of the mass of
the reactants has ended up in our
desired product okay so obviously the
higher the percentage yield the better
because it means there's less waste so
it's good in terms of economically the
higher this is if we've got a hundred
percent yield it means we've got
absolutely none of this going on if we
have a zero percent you it means none of
our reactants has ended up in our
products so let's see how to complete a
calculation so here's a typical kind of
question you could be asked about this
it says this in an industrial reaction
12 kilograms of zinc was extracted from
50 kilograms of zinc oxide calculate the
percentage yield so if I look carefully
here I can see I started off with 50
kilograms of this and I've made 12
kilograms of this so what I need to do
first of all is I need to figure out
kind of my theoretical yield so if this
was the absolute perfect perfect
situation
how much zinc would I've made from zinc
from 50 kilograms of zinc oxide so my
first step what I need to do is I need
to find my relative atomic sort of a
relative formula mass so for zinc is
just here so zinc is 65 oxygen is just
here which is 16 so up them together 65
plus 16 is 81 and on this side my zinc
I've just looked it up that's 65 okay my
next step because I need to factor in my
mass I'm just going to convert these
from kilograms to grams because I need
them to be in grams in order to use an
equation triangle that I'll show you in
a second so 50 times a thousand equals
fifty thousand grams and
on this side let me see 12 times a
thousand equals twelve thousand grams
now what my next step is this shows me
what I actually found in this experiment
but I need to find how much would I
theoretically get so in order to do that
what I first need to do is I need to use
this equation triangle that I'm gonna
show you right now okay so we have M
which stands for mass we have N which
stands for number of moles and we have M
R which stands for relative formula mass
now this could be a relative formula
mass if we're talking about a molecule
or relative atomic mass if we're just
talking about an atom like that so what
we need to do first of all is find a
number of moles of zinc oxide which
reacted so to find the number of moles
we just cover up that little N and we
need to do mass divided by the relative
formula mass so my mass is just here
50,000 and divide it by my relative
formula mass which is 81 now I need to
do that on a calculator obviously 50,000
divided by 81 equals that number there
it's a really long number now don't be
afraid if we've got or don't be worried
if we've got numbers like that they are
expected so I'm gonna write this down
and simplify it for now but I'm gonna
leave that number in my calculator
because I'm not going to round it too
early okay so I now know the number of
moles of zinc oxide that's reacting now
if I know the number of moles of this I
can figure out the number of moles of
this by looking at this thing called the
molar ratio how many molecules of this
react in order to make how many
molecules of this so I can see by
looking at my symbol equation I have a
ratio that shows that for every two
molecules of zinc oxide two molecules of
zinc are produced now a simplified
right in that ratio it's just one to one
now what that means is if I have one
molecule of this it will create it will
form one atom of this it also means if I
have 617 point two eight moles of this
it will produce because it's one-to-one
it will produce the exact same number of
these atoms so the number of moles is
going to be exactly the same for here
because it's a one-to-one ratio so that
my number of moles is six one seven
point two eight right what I'm now going
to do is I'm going to figure out my
theoretical yield remember what that
means is in a perfect world if this
reaction was perfect
what mass of zinc would I produce so
define my mass what I'm going to do is
I'm going to cover that up and I'm gonna
do my number of moles which is this here
multiplied by my relative formula mass
which is here okay so let's do that now
I've left that number in there and then
I'm going to multiply that by 65 which
equals forty thousand one hundred and
twenty three point four six grams okay
now remember what this means is in an
ideal world that is how much dick we
should theoretically produce but in
reality we produced a lot lots less so
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
save this number into my memory on my
calculator so I can use it in a second
because my final step is I need to find
the percentage yield so what I do is I
take my actual yield what it actually
found in the experiment twelve thousand
grams I'm gonna divide it by my
theoretical yield of forty thousand or
40,000 one hundred twenty three point
four six and then to express it as a
percent I'm gonna times by 100 so let's
just do that twelve thousand divided by
then the answer that I got previously so
I'm using that answer button so I can
use the exact number
which equals to zero point two nine nine
but then I need to multiply it by a
hundred so in this case my percentage
yield is twenty nine point nine one
percent this isn't very good this is
very low which means it's quite wasteful
this is going to cost me a lot of money
because some of these things must have
happened I must have lost some material
on the way or there's been unwanted
reactions or there's been incomplete
reactions for all three so that is how
we complete percentage yield
calculations thank you